cos'è sta roba bella attenti ragazzi e
per il suo video sono un po di j
non so se vi ricordate il gioco plug and
play che ho fatto mille anni fa balera
un gioco strano non guardatelo creatore
di quel gioco ha fatto anche questo
gioco che si chiama kids bambini e ci
sono queste persone che io non ho ben
capito no non so in realtà cosa si deve
fare il suo gioco però devo click le
suicidi di massa compilation non lo sono
ragazzi lo facciamo li prendiamo al volo
se carico me lo mangio sa che devo fare
la devo cliccarlo mentre cade e le
uniche di più mentre cadono ma sto male
parte giorno è allora preparatevi perché
mi ricordo come la plug and play che ha
un gioco molto molto simile allo stesso
creatore che ho fatto
tipo due anni fa 23 anni fa e non è un
senso cioè al meglio ce l'aveva il senso
madeddu interpretatelo tu anche questo
probabilmente tour interpretare dunque
per continuare così per molto cliccare
la gente che cade per terra
attenzione perché poi ha fatto talmente
bene che non capisco il semplice proprio
guarda c'è proprio una storia bellissima
si capisce tutto di quello che sta
succedendo soprattutto il nome del
protagonista
salve e l'italiano sto male malissimo
dei ai e l'italiano non ci posso che ci
sono i dialoghi a destra culo ciao avrà
un fumetto di ceo
ma cos'è è così che si trattano gli
amici schifoso da questa parte ragazzi
non sto capendo aiuto basta buttarsi nel
buco dio mio
quanti problemi dove chi siamo finiti
qua
ma cos'è ma no dai ragazzi a parte
l'apparato digestivo no è questo ragazzi
a libera interpretazione su tutti quanti
dovremmo dare una nostra riflessione sul
discorso per me fino adesso io lo verso
mari come la scuola per me questo è
stata la scuola cioè mai capito un gatto
era pieno di gente
buongiorno bisognava cronaca gommone
cadono 86
basta questo buco ma che ci fosse forse
sei che ho capito forse ho capito raga
potrebbe essere una sorta di provo a
dare soluzione perché tipo mi sento come
con i quiz andava dai ti prego di nuovo
penso che sia la riproduzione cioè se
che sono tanti piccoli spermatozoi sini
e quindi è una sorta di creto quindi
bambini c'è il loro sono qua da lui
rimasto l'unico sono tutti disorientati
non sono dove andare si buttano tutti
nel buco credo sia questo sono io che
sono malizioso da che parte da questo
unico d'accordo decidetevi a fusi gli
devo mettere tutti in ordine gli ex se
ti pare e giusto ha posto si sono visti
tutti d'accordo raga io non parola che
io sto giocando è bellissimo allo stesso
tempo non senso ma volo carino va bene
buttiamoci tutti nel buco e vediamo che
succede
quando all itis compare una ragazza a è
bravo deviamo no deviate un po tutti per
favore che con casinò si è fatto
veramente bene soggetto occhio scontrate
li porti tutti in una direzione one
direction perfetto no basta questo buco
adesso visto che li devono puntare a
differenza di prima di debuttare tutti
dentro senza un buon motivo così devo
notare nel vuoto bello fare io gli
effetti sonori sono comi copyright anno
che è una bellezza
niente continua bastare la sto facendo o
confluisce un altro punto un casino qua
c'è le precedenze c'era un finale sto
gioco dove questa si celi caga poi gli
hack agati sul serio o così ecco ragazzi
non saprei spiegarmi meglio come nascono
i bambini che è così tu li tiri fuori
via come se niente fosse sembra un
capezzoli nell'alta prova e posso
ecco ma poi
casino cosa è successo calmi tutti a
questi fan dei queen
devo fare un falli mammamia dovrà
dibattere tutti battiamo tutti le mani
all'unisono uil
esatto bravissimi allora devo googlare
un attimo erba che si è fumata il
creatore di kit cosa mi puntate
spiegatemi io più vado avanti più
capisco questo gioco non è per me un di
ogni caso sono sicuro
poverino sarei preso a lui il compito di
dover notare nel nel vuoto mi dispiace
che sia dovuto essere te a farlo zio
però quanto a te quanto a quel che non
puoi fare che tu per te qualcosa da
poter fare potrebbe esserci però qua a
domandare 8a il nuotare controcorrente
funziona ma insomma 18 dove vado li
seguono un casino allucinante aiuto o
sono figli
proprio quando stavo per tornare
indietro quindi perfetto ma esco di
sopra
[Musica]
cosa sta succedendo rai quando tornate
dalle vacanze 4 vedere i prof
tutti quanti perché una parte sporgente
non ce lo sto trovando magari loro ce lo
trovano
io di filosoficamente indotto a posto
tutto chiaro lo sciacquone
mi dispiace frate lo vado è cascato in
mezzo alla gente approdi anche tu adesso
perché se lontano tutti ma scusatemi ma
sono qua poi la gente si sposta caricava
roma come mi seguono anche decidetevi
ecco segue quelli che mi seguono follow
on four follo come su instagram
ecco ho trovato il porto scappa a prosto
mo vado da solo nel buco in mezzo
perfetto vai entra citato la prima volta
no il suo straiato che è successo
secondo me i ragazzi finisce come la
partenza scommettete a come come eccolo
vanno via del canestro stephen curry
proprio lui no no no di nuovo nome
adesso io devo applaudire tutti nel
mentre che applaudono il cad è infarcito
metri che figata sta roba e tipo se è un
sacco satis fa statix section come dice
quando ci sono quelli di facebook di
tutti i soddisfacenti
la ragazza avrà due non lo dobbiamo fare
ci prendiamo tutti quanti facciamo
questa cosa vi prego e ne ho bisogno
ne ho bisogno prossimo raduno tutti così
ragazzi vi supplico ne ho veramente
bisogno
la mia debole mente non può reggere sta
roba
non ne sono in grado poi meno male che
un computer di ultima generazione sono
questo gioco non lo regge voterà un
sacco di bambini se sono bambini si sono
tutti i bambini per gli skills capito
quindi sì alla fine secondo me è vero e
proprio sito si tratta della
riproduzione come tema centrale vista un
po in maniera filosofica va beh meno
male la gente non si ingrossa perché nel
gioco di prima sincro paura la gente
però mi sembra un intermezzo le signore
degli anelli non so perché però mi
ricordo sa cosa ci buttiamo dentro in
massa vamos camon mamma mia e casinò
raga un macello e turchi rupa che pur
dell sono troppi non riesco a farci
rientrare tutti ragazzi continua il mio
livello di youtuber in questo momento si
è alzato non so voi ma io sono
orgoglioso di me ma ci state tutte e che
continuo a buttarmi anno fa sì sì forse
ci state
ci metto un ora e mezza però ci state
oddio dopo un'ora e mezza abbiamo
riempito il bus non posso neanche
parlare soprattutto un doppio senso kids
bambini credo che sia finale a giudicare
dalla scritta adesso andiamo a googlare
perché ragazzi vi prego
cosa ho appena giocato posso ma fischia
prego prego ci mancherebbe
riconoscimenti vediamo chi è che si
canna qui
mario signor mario signor mario la
facciamo una visita dal medico allora
ragazzi guardando le recensioni del
gioco troviamo questo è il perché devi
usare i preservativi quindi ragazzo di
questo era kit bambini è un gioco basta
è un gioco perché sia piaciuto ischia
devi al canale spiace dalla campanellina
per essere aggiornati guardatevi anche
plug'n'play skater plug'n'play farisei
fa anche rima che era il precedente
quello era ancora più strano questo vi
sembrerà strano quello anche mamma mia
gola proprio trip mentale però vabbè se
rischiate vi era come sempre ci giriamo
a un prossimo video e le ragazze
[Musica]